la saison thermale 1983 est commencé
depuis plusieurs jours en franche comté
cette saison s'annonce bien
il faut dire que des efforts ont été
faits pour redorer le blason de ce
secteur
un exemple à lons le saunier où à côté
des cures pour enfants vient de se créer
un centre pour adultes
reportage de jean paul dussault henry
leiris et françois martin le thermalisme
à lons le saunier c'est une vieille
histoire à la fin du siècle dernier on
pensait déjà à utiliser certaines zones
extrêmement salée de la région après la
deuxième guerre mondiale un centre pour
enfants et créer il verra bientôt
défiler plus de 2000 jeunes par 16 24
maisons pour enfants sont installés dans
l' oms et les environs ce sont les
troubles du développement qui sont ces
thèmes et aussi les énergies à l'origine
une société privée l'établissement
thermal a été repris voici deux ans par
la mairie
celle ci tente de développer tout un
secteur destiné aux adultes municipalité
a décidé de reprendre d'arrestations et
de repères une société nouvelle avec un
agrandissement est ce pour la partie
enfants une section enfants réparé
l'établissement thermal anciens pour les
adultes
il a fallu prévenir les personnes de
lons le saunier si un rendement des ans
elle avait les appartements à louer
des villas et c'est pour pouvoir payer
les adultes qu'ils demandaient
un syllogisme nous avions donc de
l'extérieur mais il voit beaucoup
d'adultes ou de la région qui rentrent
chez eux tous les jours pour l'instant
actuellement 40 adultes ces jeunes pour
trois semaines avant le saunier et les
prévu cette session de ce type pendant
la saison 83 ce traitement concernent
les personnes touchées par les
rhumatismes et aussi celles qui
souffrent de séquelles d'accident
d'articulation dans le centre permal de
lons le saunier deux types doses non
utilisées
l'audit lédonien a légèrement salée et
riche en gaz carbonique
elle est destinée à la consommation
ensuite logic force son aspect est celui
d'une saumur allait bien sûr imbuvable
les soins se font donc de trois façons
les douches de 1 à 2 kg de pression les
bains et les massages sous l'eau
son buggy médical pour la cgil à cause
d'un aux cervicales ouvert et portal
des risques voilà
alors qu'elle avait dans quel intérêt
nous ne pouvions récurrents plus de
nicole l'ambiance est très sympa les 60
yann et la forte densité de l'autre et
salines permet une aisance très
appréciable pour le baigneur c'est
pourquoi des mouvements difficiles à
pratiquer normalement deviennent faciles
l'eau est à 34 degrés elle procure une
détente de tout le corps et ainsi qu'un
massage circulatoire les curistes pour
le moment viennent de la région mais si
le traitement est de plus en plus connu
les responsables espèrent attirer des
malades de toute la france pour la
municipalité provost mende et sannois
c'est un une activité parmi d'autres
mais il se trouve que le thermalisme
aujourd'hui intéresse pas mal de gens et
que c'est à notre avis une des cartes à
jouer de notre ville lance ce sommet a
besoin de tous ses atouts pour vivre et
aucune activité n'est secondaire ou
négligeable l'établissement thermal de
lons le saunier est donc en plein essor
il emploie actuellement 55 personnes en
saison et son développement ne peut
qu'être profitable au marché de l'emploi
lédonien